would you guys all say that attack on
titan season 4 is your most anticipated
Absa Funimation absolutely absolutely
how do you even match that hype at this
point it's the next season it's uh it
was meant to be airing this fall I think
so this summer I believe no it was
definitely it was foils really yeah
you're wrong Jo against the guy but yeah
I think it's I'm pretty sure it's airing
we was scheduled to air next fall and
I've heard from because I made a video
about the first three seasons of attack
on Titan and I've heard from pretty much
everyone who's read the manga that
season four is going to be the best
season oh no I have also heard I mean
even if it was just mediocre I feel like
it we'd stole like just think it's
amazing cuz like their journey to get
there it's been yeah and this last part
was oh my god
oh my god like it's so rare that you get
to see a series just improve over time
every season because I remember when
attack on Titan season 1 was airing
right and I was it was great it was
great but I felt like it was very
forgettable in the sense of well I
remember when season 2 aired I didn't
remember anything that happened in you
know I remember specifically in your
video of their like seasonal review you
said remember their attack on Titan and
then you just play cricket noises and be
like what I'm watching attack on Titan
season 2 is good no no I do agree that
they like season 2 cuz season 1 when I
watched it I was like okay the high
prisons yes and then season 2 came
around and actually dropped it no one
cared drinks because yeah because I
think I think what it was was that
because season 1 was you know all about
like the action and just like building
the world and yet season 2 was a lot of
politics and a lot of talking
yeah season 2 just took the pace cuz
season 1 was like a [ __ ] roller
coaster you were going up and down every
few episodes it's like you didn't know
what was gonna happen but you to me felt
a bit empty and season 2 you felt much
slower paced it was more of like a slow
burn when they focus more on the
characters yeah but I actually got
really drawn
into the world way more into season two
but by the time season 2 ended I was
like okay I'm now way more invested but
nothing really big has happens
everyone was like what the [ __ ] we've
waited four years or something twelve
episodes well because they rushed it out
yeah I mean definitely I think in season
three when that scene would leave I came
out yes I think when it just explode
yeah yeah cuz everyone saw that gif on
Twitter I was like I got a [ __ ]
catch-up I guess this is insane like
just thinking about that scene like
gives me goosebumps it's so good so good
cuz I remember season 3 part 1 I enjoyed
so [ __ ] much it sure cuz I didn't
realize I could care about the politics
that much in attack on Titan because I
remember by the time season 3 started I
was enjoying attack on Titan for
completely different reasons than season
1 yeah you don't I mean I can say the
same thing about every season right so
I've heard season 4 is going to be
completely different completely
different to what's previously been
because I mean like I don't remember
what it was but me and Aki went to the
attack on Titan exhibit mmm that they
did in Roppongi and basically it was
really tough because what what they did
was essentially they really catered to
the manga readers unfortunately yeah and
I am NOT the manga reader
so in like the later rooms of the
exhibit they're basically like on all
the walls they would have liked the
original Ganga of the manga right right
in these frames which is [ __ ] cool
yeah but then as you got further down
the exhibit they would start showing
stuff that hadn't been adapted yet right
so I was like but obviously there was
just some stuff that I couldn't really
avoid see yeah and the tiny little bits
that I did see out of context I was like
what the [ __ ]
Wow there is no [ __ ] way that's
happening and then to top it off there
was this room this was like a really
experimental move on them their part but
there was this room that you had to go
into and it was completely pitch black
room yeah and there's just audio playing
on the speakers in this pitch-black room
yeah and what that audio is is it's
audio of what Asama envisions the final
chapter of
tack on time to be so there's no visuals
there's no visuals
it's just audio and it's what he
envisions it will sound like you heard
all of it
the only thing occurred was a lot of
like background noises like ambient
noises yeah and uh and maçussa
yelling Aaron from a long way away okay
that could mean anything
I mean like I'm obviously not doing the
audio justice but it's can we get a
one-to-one reenact yeah but I mean I'm
obviously not doing the audio justice
but it sounded like when I just like
closed my eyes and heard that I was like
wow I've never been more excited for an
anime in my life it's good to know that
the anime and the manga will end with
Mikasa screaming Eren ethically a
spoiler has done for the entire [ __ ]
series